Now let's switch gears and talk about drug therapy for schizophrenia. As I
mentioned at the beginning of this lesson, the phenothiazines were discovered
in the 1950s and they were found to be more effective than placebo. That is,
when patients were given a placebo their symptoms did not improve, but when
they were given the phenothiazine their symptoms did improve. These drugs help
reduce the hallucinations, delusions, agitation, and paranoia that these
patients experienced. Therefore, these drugs became widely used. Now there are
two major groups of antipsychotics. The conventional antipsychotics, which were
made before the mid 1990s and the atypical antipsychotics, which have been
developed in about the last ten years.